hi guys in this video we're going to talk about
the two main causes of hair-loss okay number
one its nutritional deficiency and number two it
has nothing to do with nutrition it's a hormone
problem okay but this idea of taking shampoo or
conditioner that has B vitamins or collagen to
somehow I think that's going to absorb in your
hair and do any good it really doesn't work you
have to take it orally or make sure you're not
deficient okay so so let's talk about first about
the vitamin deficiencies that occur with hair and
it could be multiple but you can have a vitamin C
deficiency vitamin C is in all the leafy greens
vitamin C helps collagen hair is a collagen it's
a type of collagen is called keratin it's like a
fibrous real tough collagen so you also need trace
minerals this one is really really important
in the manufacturing of protein in the body if
you want hair skin nails arteries bone okay so
we need the trace minerals for that especially
your muscles so trace minerals are those minerals
needed in very small amounts unfortunately they're
not in our foods because they're not in our soil
anymore so unless you're consuming like sea kelp
or some type of trace mineral blend you're not
going to have it in your diet and that is a big
reason for hair loss okay now excellent collagen
so the type of collagen that someone needs to
regrow their hair is is a type 1 and type 3 okay
so that would be the type of collagen that you
would need to support that and then silica silica
is an interesting element and you don't want to
get it you want to get this in a like a food
base or an herb like a plant base okay horse
tail the plant called horse tail is loaded with
silica but silica is kind of like the probably
most abundant elements in the body it helps in
the manufacturing of collagen hair nails skin
it makes it very very shiny and tough and very
healthy and prevents wrinkles makes your nails
really strong makes the hair from protected
against splitting and then you have the B
vitamins it's interesting with B vitamins and the
trace minerals work with a lot of skin problems a
lot of hair problems because if you're deficient
with the vitamins your hair is going to fall out
okay specifically biotin and some of the other
B vitamins okay what the best way to get to B
vitamins is through nutritional yeast okay get
them from nutritional yeast so that we all the
vitamin deficiencies that you could have - that
could create hair loss all right now you also
have alopecia with this autoimmune problem and you
also have male pattern baldness or receding hair
that is high levels of DHT DHT is a very powerful
testosterone and what happens there's an enzyme
in your body that converts testosterone into this
powerful DHT - an enzyme called 5-alpha reductase
just in case you wanted to know that and if you
get a an enzyme inhibitor like stinging nettle
root it's called stinging nettle root which is
one of the top ones that I recommend that will
reduce DHT okay and that helps or Monali like to
get your hair back it's also good for prostate
it's also good for a facial hair okay so it's
and it's also good for acne all right so now
I actually have a product that has every single
one of these ingredients in it and you can get
more information below if you're interested but
the trace minerals are a plant base the collagen
is wild-caught fish skin guys type 1 and type
3 the silica is from horsetail okay which is a
plant base and the biotin is not excessively high
like a lot of times people buy up the biotin in
like 10,000 IU's and then they start getting other
side effects like acne that's because they're not
getting divided the B vitamins in the natural
complex so I actually have biotin and the B
vitamins in the natural complex so you won't get
other side effects and then I put this thing in
to actually lower the DHT and it has a food based
vitamin C so you can check it out this link down
below if you're interested but I just wanted
to kind of cover it's real simple if you just
plug in nutrition if that's what it is or if you
have alopecia or male pattern baldness you would
want to add the stinging other roots so thank
you so much for watching hey guys thank you so
much for watching please click the subscribe
button and I will see you in the next video